quand je regarde ces arbres, vous savez que
c'étaient des arbres sous
lesquels tant de nos ancêtres
marchaient,
je suis sûr qu'ils ont eu de nombreuses réunions et de
nombreuses aventures amoureuses sous ces
[Musique]
[Musique
] c'est um
ellen gabriel je suis une tortue  clan de la
nation kanyakahaga la nation mohawk
et nous sommes à
dogo qui est la forêt de pins au ghana
[Musique]
je pense que la forêt a un esprit
qui est magique et
ancien à bien des égards
le grand pin blanc qui était assez
dominant dans ce  la forêt est un symbole de
paix c'est l'arbre de la paix
pour toutes les nations iroquoises c'est
un refuge aussi
pour les animaux et les oiseaux il y a beaucoup de
longues branches et les grands arbres
vous donnent beaucoup d'ombre en hiver ce qui
est  pourquoi c'est beaucoup plus cool c'est juste un
endroit que je trouve
qui m'apporte de l'espoir et qui m'apporte la paix il
nous reste si peu de terres que
nous utilisons qui nous appartiennent
[Musique]
il y a des histoires dans notre culture
qui  parler de l'esprit du guerrier une
guerre  avant d'aller dans un journal et cet esprit
est là pour nous aider à nous protéger
[Musique]
je pense que c'est la différence entre
ce que
les peuples autochtones considèrent comme
notre relation
par rapport à des
parties de la société occidentale qui voient juste
que oh c'est un arbre que nous pouvons abattre
faire  quelques maisons et tu sais tout nettoyer
[Musique
] c'est leur maison
ce n'est pas fait pour nous c'est fait pour eux
le gouvernement
tu sais à leurs yeux ils considèrent
cette terre de la couronne
et donc ils ont décidé qu'ils pouvaient donner la
permission à n'importe qui de venir  et
développez-le
pour savoir que vous savez que quelqu'un
préférerait voir des condominiums installés
ici et que neuf trous de golf de plus
pour moi étaient tout simplement ridicules
[Musique]
nous devions protéger ces pins et il
ne s'agissait pas seulement de les protéger, il s'agissait
de
notre survie et notre protection
aussi pour que cela fasse partie de cette
obligation que nous avons en tant qu'autochtones, en
particulier en tant que femmes autochtones, si nous
abandonnons,
nous abandonnons l'
avenir et je trouve que
ce serait  d être irresponsable de renoncer à
l'avenir
[Musique]
vous